came together to do this class because
really interested in answering the
question what happened
when art starts learning right and I
think the combination especially at
Carnegie Mellon of combining art and
computer science is an exciting prospect
so the goal of the class is to build art
installations using machine learning
students took algorithms for machine
learning they try to learn to make
predictions from data or try to learn to
action later to build interesting and
thought-provoking art installation the
curator what it's doing is analyzing the
set of drawings is given over time they
try to find unique new drawings this is
typically used to detect credit card
fraud you have use your credit card in a
normal way and then you try to figure
out when is there an anomalous use of
the credit card here they're trying to
use it to figure out what is art in
what's novel in art my project at the
toilet is iam today is a prejudice robot
you stand in front of the robot and it
detects your face and it has a database
of friends and non friends and if it
likes you it'll shake your hand well the
goal for our project was to create an
interesting interactive experience for
the kids and to also very slightly teach
children about precious
and the other thing of course these
installations are doing is understanding
how people participate with artwork so
in the skeleton project to approach
something to be rejected and how does
that actually make us feel to be that
that notion to be highlighted is
something that again we're exploring
here I'm pretty excited about the class
it's really not about machine learning
is more about the art process and what
you can get out of it but it's
interesting the machine learning can
play a role like a medium like painting
or maybe light plays a role in other art
this class really helped us think a lot
more about the system and how he thinks
we created discrete the values that
float in the air
they each are checking with their
neighbors and trying to pull together so
they're kind of kind of a searching
piece and if you come near it you'll
disrupt it and they'll all shut off
really keep it still they'll all start
posting them together around you it's a
very exploratory kind of class because
no one has the final authority that
learns you know I think what we want
this class to sort of introduce is not
to see technology as something the other
side of the campus does
my brother's like pals a second just to
me another medium and to treat it just
like paint